did you know that the Quran predicted
prophesies these things happening they
get depressed and they don't want to
live anymore and in the end they take
their own lives now I just heard this
news this Quran burner in the picture
it's a Quran burner that is living in
Norway
yesterday in the age of 42 he passed
away this picture on the screen is from
the 26th of November
when he was trying to destroy our Tower
stand in Oslo in Norway they get
depressed and they don't want to live
anymore and in the end they take their
own lives and then there's another one
some breaking news on him too there are
some of the chats between Swedish Danish
politician Rasmus polidon and young boys
on the internet the convicted racist
politician who is notorious for his
so-called Crown burning Taurus and
anti-islam hate spends extensive time on
social media platform Discord chatting
with young boys about sexually explicit
topics
[Music]
although paludon has been charged with
14 offenses in the past including racism
defamation and traffic laws his online
chats did not elicit any action under
Danish law now this is some scary stuff
look anti-muslim extremists Quran burner
ramus palodin he engaged look what he's
engaging with with children with young
men but paludon often stays up late at
night and talks to young boys
this Predator this guy's a predator and
this is the kind of person that's out
there that's on the loose and he's
representing a whole country it seems
like and the country is just letting him
hit letting it slide now before I get
into how the Quran had predicted
prophesies these things and how to
prevent these things from happening
because we don't want people taking
their lives because the Quran is a
source of mercy and rahma as we call it
for the whole of mankind so it's up to
you will you take it or will you reject
it and then what will happen What will
be the consequences of that we'll touch
upon that in a moment well let's start
with the Quran burning and some of these
abuses that are going on today against
the Muslims this provocations these
provocations that are happening God
Almighty Allah is telling us for the
Believers you will surely be tested in
your possessions and yourselves and you
will surely hear from those who are
given the scripture before you and from
those who associate others with God
Almighty Allah much abuse but if you are
patient and you fear Allah indeed that
is of the matters worthy of
determination so this is nothing new
during the time of prophet Muhammad his
companions and throughout history you
have had such people doing such evil
despicable things now on the flip side
when you look at places like Norway and
Sweden where these things are happening
and you have in these places some of the
highest level of suicide why and this is
the a direct result we'll look into the
Quran what God Almighty Allah is saying
the direct result of that deep
depression when you don't have purpose
in life you don't live for something
beyond your desires that's why you see
people like this doing some of the most
heinous evil things they're miserable
they're unhappy they can't have they
don't have peace and contempt in their
life that depression keeps building up
building up and then what happens they
end up like this person did they get
depressed and they don't want to live
anymore and in the end taking his own
life but the Quran is there to save you
from that deep depression the Quran is
there God almighty Allah wants Mercy for
you that's why Prophet Muhammad was sent
as a mercy to all mankind but this is
the consequence and this what was
predicted prophesies in the Quran that
would happen let's get into this verse
from the verbatim word of God Almighty
Allah the Quran in the Quran Allah is
saying that and whoever turns away from
my remembrance indeed he will have a
depressed life and I will gather him on
the day of Resurrection blind he will
say my Lord why have you raised me blind
while I was once able to see now Allah
will say
did our signs not come to you and you
forgot them you turned away you forgot
them
and that's why this day you will be
forgotten
this is a clear
illustration of what happens when you
turn away from your creator when you
turn away from the signs that are coming
to you from God Almighty Allah and you
become a staunch opponent of the Quran
the verbatim word of God revealed to you
so Humanity as a guidance so instead of
reading the book looking for guidance to
see is there something in there that can
benefit me is there anything in there
that I can take from I'm already
depressed I'm already doing all these
heinous acts that are just compounding
the depression and then what happens
there's no peace there's no happiness
there's no Tranquility but the book is
saying is saying look if you follow it
you're going to have as Allah says truly
in the remembrance of Allah truly in the
remembrance of God do hearts find rest
now what are these signs that God
Almighty Allah is talking about I want
to share this with you this is and and
the Quran is full of these signs for
someone who is Sincere who wants to know
what's my purpose in life why have I
been created where am I going when I die
the Quran is lucid in in this there is
no ambiguity to it who your creator is
what your purpose is where you're going
when you die and these signs and I'm
going to share one of them with you if
you're someone who likes milk because
milk if it's raw if it's organic if it's
grass-fed animals that are giving you
this milk it does the body good now look
at this sign that is in the Quran it's
just one of them I'm just giving you an
example because if you want the
development of the human embryo sign
it's there the mountains acting as pegs
stabilizers for the Earth it's there the
orbiting planets and the galaxies the
unique Miracle of the fingerprint the
barrier between the two C's I mean the
list goes on with and on with all of
them the the countless signs that are in
there for a person to think hold on a
man living in a desert who couldn't read
or write there's no way that he could
have known these things it is impossible
and this this is what convinced me you
know if a person is sincere and they're
looking at it and they're adding it up
and they're like hold on one thing is
right let's say he guessed it the other
thing oh he copied it from the Greeks
from this one but what about all the
inaccuracies that they had what about
all the things that they got wrong no he
just he just somehow left all that out
it doesn't make any sense so everything
is a hundred percent accurate and this
is just one of those that I want to
share with you check this one out
amazing
[Music]
just throws out there for you to think
how is that possible who could have
known that other than the one who
created the cow the one who created
who's giving you the food who's giving
you the milk who's giving you the who's
nourishing you each and every day but we
neglect the nourishment for the heart
for the soul and what happens you turn
away from your creator you become a
Quran burner and you can go ahead and
burn all of the books you can go ahead
and get rid of them all but you can
never get rid of the Quran because this
is in the hearts and Minds this is
something that is memorized by millions
living today and will continue to be
preserved we'll continue to be memorized
we'll continue to expand and grow and
there is nothing that you can do to stop
it because this is another prophecy a
prediction
so you can either be on the side the
winning side or you can be on the side
that will end up taking you to the Hell
Fire because that fire that you're using
to burn the Quran at the end God
Almighty is also talking about the fire
that's going to burn this is another
miracle in the Quran that those skins
that will be roasted in the hell fire
that will be replaced with fresh skins
look at that because they're pain
receptors in the skin and when they go
out they don't feel the pain but God
Almighty Allah is saying in the Quran
that who replaced them with fresh skins
why you want to go ahead and be in the
Hell Fire why do you want your skins to
be replaced with fresh skin so they can
burn why do you want that be sincere
Islam is a mercy for all of mankind we
don't want people taking their lives we
want good for mankind it's like if
you're drowning in the ocean and
somebody's trying to extend their hand
peacefully to pull you out and you're
giving the man the middle finger you're
cursing him cursing his mother you what
are you doing
do you need the help you're on drugs
you're on alcohol you're you've turned
into a predator you're doing all these
evil disgusting immoral things because
you don't have guidance you don't have a
blueprint for life you fall you're
falling down a dark hole but there's
still hope there's still hope
and the Quran is that hope so don't burn
the Quran read the Quran now you might
say how do I get a copy of this book the
Quran
we'll go ahead and walk into a mosque
ask
connect with the Muslim go and ask your
questions if you're here in the United
States go ahead and visit the
deanshow.com we'll send you one as a
gift
we'll send you one as a gift make the
human connection connect with your
fellow Muslims ask those questions seek
and you shall find and ask the creator
of the heavens and earth for guidance
and he will guide you if you're sincere
and if you really want to know but if
you're someone who's just adamant about
projecting all this hate that you have
in your heart you're not looking for a
solution you're not looking for that
peace and contentment you're going to
end up soaking in your own misery you're
going to end up just compounding
your heart with more depression upon
depression and we see the result of that
so you decide at the end of the day
there's a full description in the Quran
of paradise and Islam is very clear
Loosely clear that's what we strive for
to get to Jannah would you rather be
there that you live for eternity you
never die no more depression everything
that your heart desires you will have in
paradise and you had avoid the Hellfire
just take some fire try to burn yourself
if you're trying to burn the car before
you try to burn up trying to burn
yourself and imagine being thrown into
the depths of the Hellfire that Hellfire
is 17 times more hotter than the fire in
this life why would you want to risk
that why would you want to do that
and all the evidence is there the signs
are there that this Quran is indeed from
the creator of the of the heavens and
earth
read it
ask for the guidance and you will be
amazed like so many people have who've
been sincere and have put this to Quran
to the test hopefully these words have
been of some encouragement describe if
you haven't already hit that
notification Bell we'll see you next
time here in Nadine show until then
peace be with you assalamualaikum
I am an adult we're here with Uhaul Law
Firm yes yeah all right guys so we
signed everything here
what's up gotta get the keys now
[Music]
[Applause]
Muslims around here it's it's pretty
huge and uh like this the place the
location that you opened in basically is
far further south from the other other
big massages and everyone I know a lot
of people that I used to I come my
cousin lives nine minutes from here
another Uncle of mine lives about five
to ten minutes from here this area
opened up in an area that it's much
needed and this size yeah I mean this
the center this Center is much needed
for this area and the idea of this
Center is needed for the whole stick
because we don't have anything like that
in the whole state that was censor where
it's gonna basically nurture and
basically educate and it's gonna
basically spread Islam